- [Interviewer] No, you
were doing a good job
of supporting yourself
and doing everything right?
- Exactly.
Like, I don't know what I did wrong
but I lost everything.
Not because of a drug
addiction or anything.
It was just,
it's not fair.
- [Interviewer] Alright Loyalty.
- Hi.
- Loyalty where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I'm from Nashville, Tennessee.
- [Interviewer] Tennessee.
And tell me about your family.
Did you grow up with both your parents?
- I did for the first part,
but my mom, she was a heroin addict.
I was born four months prematurely
and,
that had a whirlwind of like
different responsibilities
that I had to take care of
throughout my life.
Like mentally, physically
challenges.
I had both my parents, yeah but,
my mom, she sadly died of an overdose.
I was 13 years old
and shortly before that I
did my first shot of heroin
with her.
And,
my dad, he passed away at
17, I was 17 years old.
He died in a car accident.
- [Interviewer] Hmm,
You had a rough childhood.
- Yeah.
It played it out a lot in my life.
You know like,
the choices I make are altered
and the feelings I feel are altered
from the normal perspective
society's perspective of normal.
I might look normal, act
normal, but I don't feel normal.
I didn't have the responsibilities
shown to me.
I didn't have certain like morals and shit
that I should know
and that should be placed in my life,
through my parents, I
wasn't able to get that
because it was cut off
at such an early age.
- [Interviewer] How old are you now?
- I'm 25.
- [Interviewer] 25.
- I just turned 25.
- [Interviewer] During your childhood,
was there any abuse of any sort?
- No, my mom, she did really well
like the first couple years
of my life to hide that
but I really don't remember that.
But she took care of me for the most part
made sure I went to all
my doctor's appointments.
She was a good mom.
She just had an addiction.
- [Interviewer] So no physical abuse?
- Oh no.
- [Interviewer] Sexual abuse?
Just a mom who is addicted to drugs?
- Yeah.
Whenever I lost her, I lost everything.
My dad wasn't there for
us, neither one of us.
He really wasn't a part
of my life like that.
- [Interviewer] Where
did you go after that?
- After my mom died?
- [Interviewer] Yes.
- I went into state's custody
and I wasn't good enough
for like foster care
because I have mental problems,
I have autism.
It's a, it's a moderate case,
it's not high or nothing,
but it's just due to the premature birth.
I was born four months premature.
My mom had had overdosed
and she was gonna kill both of us.
So the hospital like did
an emergency C-section
and,
yeah,
saved both of us.
- [Interviewer] So you went
out on your own or what age?
You went out on your own at what age?
- 13.
Well, state's custody,
they let me out at 19,
but I felt alone, I was alone.
The state, they only did-
- [Interviewer] Between
13 and 19, where were you?
- Oh, states custody.
I was like in and out of like
group homes, residentials,
treatment facilities.
- [Interviewer] But no parents, to say?
- No, I was my own parent.
- [Interviewer] And were
drugs continuing for you
after that?
- They were altered a little bit
because of the fact that I
was in group homes and shit
but there's ways to get that shit
and pretty easy people,
not even with the real bit.
Yeah, not really.
I was pretty addicted.
11 years, I spent my life doing heroin.
11 years of my life, I'm 25.
That's crazy.
- [interviewer] Yeah.
So today you're living where?
- I'm on skid row .
- [interviewer] How long you been here?
- About eight months.
I was living in Carson.
I had moved out here with one of my exes
and this was about three years ago.
And he came out here for a job
and it was in construction
for an agency and shit.
They wanted him to move over to Arizona
so we swapped Arizona
and I found an agency for
me, it was a temp service.
and I started working like daily for them
and I was getting paid okay
but it just enough to get us by.
And then I had a job offering,
and it was crazy
'cause it was like a lot of
physical work, physical labor
and it was a man's job.
I actually started.
I don't have like a degree
or nothing like that.
Like I just worked solely off of what
my boyfriend had taught me
and what the temp agency had taught me
like do daily things.
But I did everything from
flooring to concrete,
to fences, putting up
drywall, all kinds of shit.
Sorry, can I cuss?
- [Interviewer] Sure.
- Okay.
- [Interviewer] Did you
graduate high school?
- I didn't, I did not.
- [Interviewer] How far did you go?
- I do have my GED though.
- [Interviewer] That's good.
I did get my GED, but I didn't,
actually I didn't even make
it past the sixth grade.
I dropped out.
Whenever my mom died, I stopped everything
that's why they had me for
like, what is it called?
Unruly kid.
That's why I couldn't go up for
like foster care or nothing.
It wasn't because I was like
physically like homicidal
or nothing like that,
but
I was just a bad kid,
the government portrayed me to be.
- [Interviewer] So now
that you're on skid row,
how are you supporting yourself?
- Oh yeah, yeah.
Through the temp agency,
I had a job offering
and of course my educational
background, I do have my GED,
so that helped me out a lot.
And I bumped up to working not
for the temp agency anymore,
but I moved to Carson.
I had a house.
I had a house for myself and my boyfriend.
I had two cars, one that
I was paying for my own,
and one, I was paying
for it for my boyfriend
I was really putting in like all the-
and I enjoyed it,
I enjoyed every moment of it.
It helped me quit heroin.
It made me a better person.
And sadly I lost all of
that eight months ago
'cause of COVID-19.
I got laid off from my job
and I couldn't take
care of myself anymore.
I wasn't living off of no
benefits from the government.
And honestly, I still don't
know how to do any of the GR
and shit like that.
I don't get that.
I'm like here with nothing
because I don't know what to do.
Like nobody's ever like
sit me down and told me,
"Hey, you can do this for
yourself, you can do this."
- [Interviewer] So if it
hadn't been for COVID,
you'd be working still.
- Yeah, I would still have my job,
I still have my house, my car.
I'd probably still have my fiance.
But,
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- I lost everything.
First it was my job,
and then it was my house, and now my car.
And then my fiance took
off of me in his car.
So I had to pay for that too.
Still making payments on that.
And I have no money income.
The EDD stuff,
they had some kind of malfunction,
somebody was using some kind
of something on my account
and I haven't heard nothing back from 'em.
So I don't know what's up with that.
And I'm like,
I shouldn't be doing as
bad as I'm doing right now.
And it's just crazy.
I lost everything like that.
Everything I had to show for the past
24 years of my life
is gone.
In a matter of three months, I lost it.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
And how are you supporting yourself now?
- I'm not.
I'm like,
I feel horrible,
I've never been like this down in my life.
I've always took care of myself.
I've always had somebody
that cared about me around me.
And now I just have nobody.
Sorry.
Its pretty hard.
Especially being in one of the,
honestly the best and the
worst place I could be
to be homeless right now.
- [Interviewer] Are you
selling yourself to guys
that'll pay you?
- Honestly,
I did have a pill not too long ago.
And it was just because
of my new addiction
and that's to fentanyl.
You ever heard of that?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- I'm allowed to say that, right?
- [Interviewer] Sure.
A lot of heroin addicts
move over to fentanyl.
- I started doing fentanyl
whenever I lost my shit.
I started doing it heavy
about six months ago
and,
I've been going downhill rapidly,
lost a lot of weight
and I care about myself
like my body's a temple,
but it's obviously it's
not too much a temple now.
Honestly, I feel sorry for myself.
And I shouldn't,
that's the last thing that I ever want
anybody to feel for me,
feel sorry for me, feel bad for me.
- [Interviewer] No,
you were doing a good job
of supporting yourself
and doing everything right.
- Exactly.
I don't know what I did wrong,
but I lost everything.
Not because of a drug
addiction or anything.
It was just,
It's not fair.
- [Interviewer] Do you have kids?
- I don't, thank God.
Thank God I don't have kids.
That'd be horrible.
- [Interviewer] Do you have friends?
(sighs)
Other than street acquaintances?
- Honestly, I don't even
have like acquaintances.
I have people that I talk to,
I don't kick it with nobody.
I'm a loner.
After the pimp situation,
I actually, I got abused by a pimp.
So I like took off with a trick.
I haven't seen him since.
I heard he's tryna find me,
but,
if he does, what can I do?
What is he gonna do?
If he wants his money,
I don't have his shit.
What money?
But-
- [Interviewer] What do
you worry about most now?
- Now?
What's going to happen next.
I wasn't putting any thought into that
until about a month ago.
(siren cries)
I've just been pretty down now.
I don't know where to go,
I don't know what to do,
I don't know where to turn,
I don't know who talk to.
I don't know,
I don't know.
I don't understand it.
I can't comprehend the fact-
- [Interviewer] Are you depressed?
- That I'm like this.
I don't know how to get myself out of it.
(sirens cries)
Yeah, really depressed.
- [Interviewer] You get depressed,
anxious as well?
- All of it.
- [Interviewer] All of it.
- But I try to not show it.
Those tears you just saw, that's rare.
That's rare.
- [Interviewer] Do you feel shame
about how your life is falling apart?
- I don't.
I don't feel shame.
I don't feel embarrassed.
I just feel
I just don't deserve it.
I didn't deserve it.
I mean, it's my fault that
I continued to go down.
I could have done other things
but could've should've would've,
I don't even know what I
could've done when it happened.
I wasn't thinking,
I didn't know what to do.
Honestly my life was given
to me on a silver platter
even though I went through
all the trials and errors
and shit that I went through,
it was personally
a blessed learning experience.
Everything I did,
it had a purpose and meaning
and I learned from it.
I either succeeded from
it or I learned from it
good or bad.
- [Interviewer] What's
the most important lesson
you've learned.
- Honestly,
I've learnt
that my error is that
do to others what I want them to do to me,
like treat me wise.
- [Interviewer] So you're kind to others.
- And I expect it.
- [Interviewer] And you
expect that in return.
- But I shouldn't.
- [Interviewer] And
especially not down here.
- I guess my moral
right now would be like,
stay strong,
stay put together as much as I can.
I don't really know.
I don't know.
I don't feel like myself right now.
So I don't know what to tell myself.
I don't know what advice to give myself.
I don't...
If I did,
I probably would have done
something about it by now.
It's like, I'm waiting for somebody
to,
push me into a direction
or to tell me what to do.
I know nobody's made to do that,
nobody's gonna do that shit
but hopefully by the grace
of whoever the hell is
here above me
or below me, whatever,
I hope they helped me
somehow give me some kind of-
- [Interviewer] You still have some hope?
- I have a little bit,
but honestly,
being in the streets man,
it's like,
right now could be the
last time I'm breathing.
I've seen people get killed
right in front of me.
I've seen people get hit by cars and shit.
Like beating each other to death,
I've see more on skid row than
I've seen in any horror film.
(chuckles)
People are crazy man.
These drugs are no joke.
If I had any advice to give to anybody
it would be,
not to take anything for granted.
I took everything,
I didn't take it for granted, but I didn't
I didn't appreciate it
the way I should have.
And I feel like that's maybe why I lost it
the way that I lost it.
Or maybe I was just too blind to see
that there was a different
opportunity there
that I wasn't able to see
it at the moment and I lost.
It's just a lot of like
negative thoughts about
what I could have done.
Not regrets but,
along the same lines.
- [Interviewer] Have
you've been in love before?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] Have
you been in love before?
- It depends what kind of love,
like in love with somebody else or?
I'm not sure,
I don't think so.
Because,
the way,
I still do love myself,
but,
not as much as I did a year ago.
I love myself.
And I know what love feels like
and the definition of love.
I can explain all of that.
A year ago, I could tell
you that shit, like there.
I was so proud of myself
and I assume that to be
the same kind of feeling
that I would have towards somebody else.
A little bit different
but,
I loved myself.
So I know what it feels
like to have loved,
but,
I felt more lost than love.
Heartache.
(sirens cries)
What's your definition of love?
Maybe I can answer that
a little bit better.
- [Interviewer] That's a great question.
There's so many types of love.
There's romantic love.
There's like you said, self love.
There's the love you have for
your children or your family.
- And that's two entirely different ones?
- [Interviewer] They're
all very different.
And I think I would,
my question to you was,
have you been in a romantic relationship
that was significant?
- No.
- [Interviewer] No...
- I've been in a relationship.
- [Interviewer] You're young.
- I was engaged.
- [Interviewer] Been in love?
- I feel like I fell in love.
(chuckles)
- [Interviewer] If you
have to think about it,
you weren't.
- But...
- [Interviewer] Because what I've been,
there is no mistaking it.
- I don't think I've -
- [Interviewer] There's nothing like it
- Experienced that yet.
I don't think I've been granted
the gift of experiencing
love that a man could give
me or warming or whatever.
I don't think I have,
because if I have, I think
I would be able to tell you.
- No, you'd know it if you had it.
When it happens, it's unforgettable
and there's nothing
that feels as good, but-
- Yeah I know.
- [Interviewer] But you haven't yet.
And that's fine, you're young.
- I'm scared to feel love.
(chuckles)
No.
- A lot of people are.
- I'm not scared.
Fear of getting hurt,
fear of success,
fear of all these kinds of things
stops people from letting it happen.
- Most of those emotions
got cut off in my childhood.
So..
(chuckles)
- [Interviewer] Loyalty,
I wish you the best of luck out here.
You're in the worst spot
you could have found.
- Oh I thought you were about to say
I'm the worst person you've talked to.
- [Interviewer] No,
you're in the worst spot
you could possibly choose to end up.
- You have any advice for me?
- [Interviewer] If you
can figure out a way
to get away from the drugs,
that would be a big one.
Getting away from this
neighborhood is key in doing that.
Finding employment and a routine
that can keep you on track
would be a great step.
- See I had that.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, I know you did.
I know that's what's
frustrating about your story
is that you kinda had everything lined up.
were you doing, were
you using heroin then?
- No, because of my job,
I got tested like regularly.
That's why..
- [Interviewer] So you were
clean and you were working
and everything was great.
- Yeah.
(chuckles)
- [Interviewer] And now you're homeless
- I wasn't even smoking weed.
A box of cigarettes would
last me damn near a week.
- [Interviewer] Do you blame COVID
for kind of your downfall.
- I do, I do.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
That's the only reason why my job,
'cause it's like government based,
so if they laid off a bunch of people,
a bunch of people got
laid off 'cause of COVID
that worked for like for the government.
I didn't work for the government,
but I worked for somebody that
worked for the government,
Like a subcontractor.
- [Interviewer] I suspect
there may be a lot of stories
similar to yours.
A lot of people are taking
the hit because of COVID.
- [Interviewer] And hopefully
they can relate to this
and it helps them somehow.
Maybe they have some kind of advice.
Imma definitely read the comments.
Maybe somebody has got
something to help me out.
I need it, I need it,
I need it.
But I don't blame COVID
for how I am right now.
Right now is solely because of me
and because of how I pitied myself,
of how I took the whole situation.
I shouldn't have took
it the way I took it,
but I did and now I have
to face the consequences.
- [Interviewer] That's
a very healthy statement
you just made.
I think that if you start
taking responsibility
for your situation,
is the first huge step.
- Yeah.
I don't blame COVID for
making me another drug addict.
No, I'm not like that.
I see that that's me.
That's me that made that mistake.
But I do blame COVID
for making me homeless.
(chuckles)
Shit.
- [Interviewer] Alright Loyalty.
Thank you so much for
coming and talking with me
I wish you all the luck in the world.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] You still have a great
long life ahead of you.
- I hope so.
(chuckles)
- [Interviewer] A couple of lucky breaks
and you could be back where you were.
- Oh yeah.
- [Interviewer] I hope you get that.
- [Loyalty] Well, thank you for having me.
- [Interviewer] Thank you.